[Music]
what's up everyone hello welcome to
simulation today we have the pleasure of
sitting down with Arvind Gupta thank you
thank you so much for having me I'm
super excited for this conversation and
likewise it's been I think 2 years since
we met and in the bio and had some
mentoring there
I love the companies love the mission
I'm excited to talk about that today we
have a good amount to talk about so
Arvind was 10 years in design and the
design director at IDEO and then which
what would you call I do so ideas a
design consultancy but really it was the
organization that helped make creativity
accessible help big design accessible to
everyone through something they promoted
called design thinking
but really it's a process of creativity
and I think it's something that has been
a part of me and become a part of me and
something I'm bringing to biology now
yes anyway yes did that and that whole
idea of design thinking is now because
they've kind of popularized it they
helped popularize absolutely rather than
just making something it's like ok well
as you make it how is going to impact
other things spent all that and then so
the last about five years now a general
partner at SOS ventures and then also
founder of indie bio mm-hmm so what is
SOS ventures how did you guys end up
starting that because that's what's Sean
that's a Sean of Sullivan yeah so SOS is
Sean O'Sullivan ventures and it was
really interesting I was in China
building the product development team
for I do in Asia and while I was there I
had been getting into this whole idea of
startups or thinking about how do you
create products quickly how do you move
faster than markets and so I started
mentoring for a hardware accelerator
called hacks when it first started and
that happened to be run by my partner
Cyril and Cyril was working with Shaun
this is back when ssv didn't really know
what it was it was that's right and
every like in and that's when Shaun was
really more of a family office and so
they tried this whole accelerator thing
with hacks and and it really made sense
on many levels and and did exceedingly
well and so SOS V Shaun thought ok great
let's let's look at this model and
double down on it and use this as a
model for investing and so rather than
like a YC or 500 startups or tech stars
where it's horizontal and you get any
tech startup doing whatever all in the
same room we go very deep in one
vertical and say ok there is an
ecosystem that's going to be more
important than almost anything else and
when you're vertically you could build
that ecosystem because there's a there's
a benefit to that it's a creative at
that point and and there's a benefit to
the horizontal one as well different
benefits absolutely absolutely and so
but when you're talking about something
like biology you know it becomes you
know the horizontal is within you know
life sciences yeah and and it becomes a
thing of its own and so as I started to
get into this idea of how do you build
how do you build products but being able
to do that in them in the most efficient
way possible and with the most impact
possible it led me to sort of to the
venture side a bunch of VC started
asking me hey you know you should be on
the venture side I had just finished
doing a startup with my wife called
starters which was a fitness app yeah so
but it was pretty amazing you know like
I designed the Samsung Galaxy curve and
you know the it gets out there and you
see people use it and you know you're
kind of like oh okay cool I did a fit
this app with my wife called starters
that we built because we wanted to help
our parents stay fit and healthy as they
got older and so we thought through that
problem how do you get your parents off
the couch right like what's that first
step is they don't go to the gym
everyday necessarily they don't like
they don't know how did that first step
is the hardest part right it's not they
don't want to and so we designed an app
solely around that moment and then we
launched it and very quickly it was
being used by thousands of people around
the world in over 70 countries and my
wife Christa Christa was getting these
emails like you know you've changed my
life and I was like man I've you know
spent a decade in design you know like
I've had stuff in the San Francisco
Museum a modern art and no one has ever
written me an email that I've changed
their life and it snapped into focus
what am I actually doing with my life
yes and what is my purpose and that's
when I started to really say all this
was happening at the same time venture
capitalists were like oh you should go
to the VC side I saw the power of doing
startups of having an idea and then just
having the drive to to execute against
it and seeing the change you could make
with that give us a quick idea of the
starters app what was that first step
that that got them to move yeah oh so
the yeah so this starters app is
basically it's it's kind of like a
social network it along with these
videos these really short videos that
Chrissa actually filmed herself
exercising yep and then when the person
completes the exercise mimics the video
it gets pushed on a push notification to
their friend list and they have to have
completed the exercise and/or covered
the push to get it pulled salute and
then it goes through the social network
and they're like look they're working
out yeah that's exactly it and then
there's a leaderboard yeah amongst that
so it gamma fide you know the whole
thing is still alive now still live now
yeah totally
uh you could go download it now on the
App Store and start exercising today
yeah get started yeah but yeah it was a
it was just a phenomenal experience in
every every single way
written like that in to you and reading
it and having that whole feeling of
recognition and helping someone else
that reset the way that you thought
you're like how do I get more of that to
happen that's exactly it and and so I
was in a position then where I was
coming back to the u.s. back to the Bay
Area and thinking okay well what what do
I do now I see the power of being nimble
and agile and focused and I've also see
the power of like working with extremely
large organizations to drive change
on a different level and and so I start
talking a lot of VCs
and finally a couple were you know
really shared with me that great VCS is
really just about mentoring and and just
strong mentoring you have to love
mentoring other people and I think
that's and you you have to love also or
not being in the spotlight I think
that's something that we lose a little
bit in the trip in the current VC
landscape where it's a lot of it's about
brand and trying to get out there but I
think the very best VCS are more behind
the scenes because they're not making
the decisions about themselves as much
as they're making decisions about the
companies it's a really important skill
set that my mentors have helped impress
upon me and I think is really important
so anyway long story short is like okay
the ability to help companies or help
small companies groups of three or four
people productized technology right and
drive change through that is something
that I became very excited about and so
then the question is in what types of
technology and so yeah not many people
know this but I have a background of
genetic engineering way backing it UC
Santa Barbara I was working on the
tetrahymena thermophilus ciliate and
it's a very interesting silly it's got
34 copies of its genome and so there's a
bunch of reasons it's a it's a good
model organism study
but this is the very beginning of modern
molecular biology I'd call it like where
we were doing PCRs by hand you know so
it was mid 90s you know late 90s and so
it was kind of it was kind of an
interesting time but it was just too
slow for me I didn't have the patience
so and that and so you nailed it and so
when I was looking at and I always had
loved biology even at IDEO I wrote an
article I was a co-author on a paper for
the Journal of commercial biotechnology
talking about how Design Thinking could
be used in a in a biotech setting to
improve and increase speed of pace of
innovation but you know so I always
watched and because it was always my
first love biotech but eventually I saw
that okay well if I go to venture
capital I think the cost of biology had
dropped enough and the speed of biology
it's increased enough to the point where
it was possible to do biotech at a seed
stage level yeah and no one had ever
thought about it that way it was still
all biotech super expensive ten million
dollars twenty million dollars minimum
check size and I was like no I think you
could probably go sooner than that and
be scrappy and find product market fit
and vertical integration so that you
have all the components that you need
for them to be successful in especially
in SOS ventures in your office space
there's a lab that's right and so when I
started looking at biology so what makes
what makes biotech expensive well all
the capital equipment so why don't we
just abstract that out build a lab for
everyone that everyone can share and now
you're using you've converted your
capital expenses into operating expenses
and I could do risk your idea on a much
smaller dollar basis and so that was the
birth of a new bio in my mind and so I
came and I gave that idea to Sean I said
listen I'll I'll join us was V if this
is something I can build and he's like
that looks great let's build it and that
was that was the beginning that was in
2014 I joined and and then set set to
work and how did you land the San
Francisco what
was the idea for that space so I live in
San Francisco obviously and uh and I
think one of the important things in
terms of space is it's an accelerator
which means a new group of people come
every six months right so in thinking
about a location for something like that
and knowing that I'm gonna draw from
around the world you want people to go
to a destination right so it's not just
it's kind of like you put a conference
in Vegas you're like oh I go have fun in
Vegas and there's a conference or you
put a conference in Hawaii or something
oh okay it's the same thing if I put in
the middle of nowhere even if it's
slightly cheaper it's a harder push to
get a spouse or something like that to
go with you yeah where it's okay we go
to San Francisco there's a bunch of
opportunities outside of just this to
run on the BART line we're right on the
bar line so that that nailed the actual
location down so we're on Jesse Street
right Inman Plaza between fifth and
sixth and six and that location is a
stone's throw from the BART line which
allows you to live anywhere in the
entire but greater Bay Area yeah and be
at Indy by within a half an hour that's
a really important part so you get like
so you get 15 companies from around the
world every six months and now they're
not hamstrung by the location and
transportation and things like that it
gives everyone ultimate flexibility and
so really it was a again you know you
make that decision in service of the
companies and then it becomes something
that's good and you needed space that
had enough both an electrical grid that
could support all of your equipment yeah
but also is enough space to support all
that equipment enough room for all the
16 companies to have enough desk space
open yeah open floor desk space so then
someone this is so interesting to be
able to think about these first moments
but in 2014 when you were doing kind of
the first inaugural batch what did that
look like man so the funny thing is I
got the space you know it's being pushed
through zoning in the city I'm having
the mayor come and do the cutting and
all this kind of stuff so it's
aboveboard and all that and of course
lower I'm like all man the the deadlines
for you know the start date is fast
approaching I'm like dude we're not
gonna make it I was like okay what do we
do and do I push the date back and it's
like no way we can't push the date back
so I did a quick search and found
randomly a biotech company shutting down
the dog patch and that company was
vacating their space I called got their
space and we within a month moved all of
our equipment in and was able to start
on time and my wife was pregnant with
our first daughter at the time and and
she gave birth to look our first our
first girl three days before the first
batch started so it's pretty this is a
fun time you know like you know you
spent the time in the hospital and then
as soon as we were got out of the
hospital I went like to Indy bio and
like welcome sandy bio right we're all
gonna figure this out together but it
was great you know we had like Clara
Foods in that class X 10 which is now of
a winery we it was just a really
remarkable and inaugural class and in
the Dogpatch to start in the dog patch
in that lab six-month period for the
four months the accelerator is actually
for four months and the first one was
actually three months a little shorter
we got to four months cuz he saw the
three months was just a little bit too
fast and so yeah we were in the dog
patch and and and went through all that
and we had our first demo day actually
in our current space so show Z how far
we've come as a now we hold it in the
Opera House in San Francisco right now
so it's it's been a really remarkable
journey and one I'm really thrilled to
go on with other biotech entrepreneurs
and you had to put together a really
strong team of people in order to be
able to handle this so then you've had a
great talent on the team to help you run
Indy bio to its fullest and then the
companies that have come on have had
mentorship and guidance of you along the
way they've also had this so the second
the second cohort moved into the news
for the new space that you know
yes exactly in the second queue so then
the lab was finally ready you know we
did a little you know ribbon-cutting and
all that kind of stuff and and we moved
in and it was great in the second cohort
had like Memphis meets and had a very
good therapeutics company valley down a
medical and it was just really it was
cool to see you know we were learning
starts were learning and most
importantly I think the world was
learning that you can do biotech at an
earlier stage de-risk it and and get
these scientists to be entrepreneurs it
it was a wholly open question yeah not
one person believed that to be true
before we started Indy bio that's a
remarkable thing to think about us it's
still to this day I go to the East Coast
and you know we talk about what we do
and they're like yeah but when do you
bring in the you know the real
management team yeah you know like we
don't like we're like we teaching them
to do that we're giving them more the
opportunity to learn it and I think you
know it's very also important to yes we
do we do share the common mistakes in
the past but you can't teach people to
be entreprenuer NAND they'll go through
the through through the lessons
themselves so I'm not presumptuous
enough to believe that we're doing it
right like it's it's the entrepreneurs
that are doing it we're there to support
and help them grow and hopefully help
them avoid some common mistakes that
commonly kill companies yes and that's a
another aspect of the de-risking is that
you're not only providing them with the
space that decreases the cost so much
and all the equipment but then also
you're de-risking by helping them with
this toolkit of entrepreneurship but
also of other skill sets that you're
making them helping them understand and
learn and then with this d risking
process all of a sudden it's easier to
have scientists become entrepreneurs and
then even on places in the world where
they didn't know before that it was
possible to have biology be accelerated
so quickly now you've done 80 80 81
companies exactly yeah with another you
know with another 15 coming in shortly
you know it's yeah it's pretty
remarkable and I think one of the
reasons we're doing this as we're able
to solve massive world problems so
before you know in old biotech the whole
thing was around okay here's a team from
Harvard that's won a bunch of Nobel
prizes or we're gonna give them 50
million dollars in there figured out
because they're the smartest people in
the world and it doesn't quite work like
that you know smart there's a lot of
smart people are everywhere and what you
need are a lot of people working on the
world's biggest problems yeah because if
you do that there's just not enough
teams to work on the world's biggest
problems and so they're just not gonna
get solved in as rapid of fashion so if
we could take a more portfolio approach
to solving things like the food supply
chain for 10 billion people on the
planet clean water for the same amount
of people global warming and an
eliminating the terrible effects of
actual global warming through biology
these are all biological processes right
and so using biology as a technology we
can go broader than just human health
care and and and longevity and go find a
much broader approach an application
space those are all trillion-dollar
markets and that's what we're doing
we're trying to take a portfolio
approach to solving each of those
trillion auto markets yep and then you
lists you look you're listing this
importance of of what we were talking
about before the show which was
civilization design now we see these
systems that are a little bit and
they're not twos they're not sustainable
enough or they're not they don't work
for everyone well enough and so what is
the way that we can do food that we can
do healthcare that we can do these
different aspects of
of of biology leveraging technology
leveraging entrepreneurship with the
science in order to to make the world
better across these fields so you've had
you were listening Claire Foods Memphis
meats
those are like these are the food aspect
yes so there's some food aspects but
then there's also these these these
therapeutics these ways to to enhance
the body some ability to rejuvenate and
so then there's the you know then that's
that's these this isn't even including
doing things like storing digital data
in DNA so there's like this wide swath
of areas that you're covering that are
crucial thank you yeah food gets a lot
of coverage on the press you know is
because it's so accessible and easy to
understand that's so that's easy to talk
about you know the the journalists talk
to me all the time about this they're
like so you know you're doing all this
food what what is it that no one's ever
asked me I'm like we're trying to cure
so many diseases but it's harder for
people to understand that aspect yeah
so yeah we want to cure disease we want
to help remediate want you know mine
waste water and make actual large areas
of the land more arable it so
agriculture is an important not just the
food aspect for the agriculture aspect
and the actual like clean water we want
to solve for scarcity issues and
scarcity is increasing every single day
on a number of fronts and so what we're
trying to do is use biological
efficiencies to alleviate those
scarcities and so you know like you
mentioned catalog you know storing
information and DNA I mean now we're
talking right now if you think about a
flash drive how long is a flash drive
last and maybe a hundred years I'm
guessing before things start to degrade
and you know a lead breaks and it's gone
we are still finding DNA and prehistoric
animal
wasn't able to decode it right and read
it so if you start start storing the
entire civilizations information
database and knowledge in a vial right
in an Eppendorf tube this big and be
able to store that for a billion years
that's a fundamentally different way of
looking at things exactly and so that's
the things we're trying to figure out
right and those are the things we're
trying to fund and we could fund it
because we can lower we can take that
kind of risk since our business model
allows that so I see that as our job
literally like we should be to like
we're funding a company right now that's
taking a nutritional approach to cancer
therapeutic and they're gonna go they're
going through you know FDA trials and
the 60 Mouse initial in vivo study but
it's something that Big Pharma or old
biotech VC venture capital would would
look at that and say oh it's too risky
you know 50 is thirty million dollars
into that how can we you know it's too
much risk because that's the kind of
Rochette size they're right so it's more
canonical so that allows us to be non
canonical and some of it works and some
of it doesn't but when it works it tends
to be industry defining or game-changing
and I think cell AG is probably our best
example and why it comes up so much of a
industry redefining category that came
out of nowhere three years ago
everything from the biomaterials we had
Joe oh that's cool yeah awesome he ended
up we ended up sitting down with him
that at the demo day which was great too
neuro tech being able to compute with
neurons yes
stem cells Diagnostics regenerative
medicines these are all aspects of
biology that are being accelerated by
technology that are then able to help
make a more sustainable world so how
about walk us through so these are all
these different examples eighty of these
different companies now
what does this look like for somebody
that wants to get involved with their
biology company they become the submit
long form maybe video interview what is
what's that process like how do I get
chosen it's pretty easy if for the
companies but we have an online
application so you go to Indy bio CO and
dot CEO yep and and you're able to you
know see apply and there's a there's a
questionnaire that you can fill out
right shouldn't take more than an hour
to fill out the application you can
submit a video you know application
alongside it if you'd like it's not
required but then we see it and whether
or not we meet you you know at a postdoc
association lunch or we've never met you
and you apply online everyone puts it
online
okay so then we review it weekly
everything that's come in and we start
to look for things that are
game-changing trillion dollar markets is
this problem addressing a billion people
or a billion dollars yeah
if so you know are these the founders
that are gonna be able to do it so we
talk to the founders we have a first cut
of interviews that we then do and we
that's mostly a scientific due diligence
interview understanding the founders
science fit yeah and then we move
because you know of course if the
science is becoming of the entrepreneur
they have to be able to drive all that
yeah and then from there if that all
looks good we look at the holistic
business proposition and we do another
interview where we talk more about go to
market strategy what is the actual
business that could become and it's a
very interactive process it's not like
tell us the right answer or the that's
it we're not looking for a right answer
we're looking for a collaboration
actually so it's us also engaging you
know how collaborative are these people
do they want that you know is this we
see we learn a lot there and I think
that's a big part of it it's not
necessarily
we don't invest in ideas I don't invest
in ideas we invest in problems and
people right yeah and then the
businesses flourish because of you have
the right problem with the right people
yep that's really this kind of a secret
of ours yeah and so we have that and
this often times it's now two or three
interviews cuz Oh have you thought about
this or have you thought about that you
might want to do some research there
they go and do the research come back we
have another conversation so often it's
very laborious are you still doing all
of the interviews we're doing all the
interviews I'm in the all the interviews
we have so everyone on the nd bio team
has to agree on every single team that
comes in and so you know it's a huge
amount of effort but it really pays off
during the batch and really pays off the
demo day as you see yeah you get a build
a close family of companies every cohort
so so there's about you said about 200
or so apply for four four hundred four
hundred apply and then only four fifteen
get in okay and then the and you can
have anywhere from an idea to already a
million dollars in sales it can be
anywhere absolutely we like to be the
first check-in we're not always the
first check-in you know one company like
yeah yes like a check for money so yes
that first check mark first actual
cashing no because I think often time
with that does everyone is in the same
place everyone gets the same deal it's
uh again it's it feels in family deals
to fifty two hundred fifty thousand four
four percent percent 8 that's 8 percent
of the company ok ok
yeah and that's and that's enough money
to get them in mentorship and the space
that gets him enough to get them to the
next stage where they're either
typically already selling the product or
raising more money in order to
have they already have a proof of
concept that's right it's a 70% of our
companies raise money and Evans 0-0 70
and the average raises two point 1
million dollars Wow Wow and the average
valuation is not approaching nine
million dollars 10 million dollars so
it's a yeah it's a sum it's a function
again of attacking large markets with
great founders you said and I think
that's really it the business could
change everything could change but those
two things can't change yes the founder
can't change if the founders are
changing now you don't know what you
have anymore
that's like your design thinking
mentalities coming into play again is
identifying these major global problems
and then also making sure that it's the
right founding team that they have the
right vision that they are thinking
about it at this massive scale that they
know about the short-term things that
they have to do in order to make it
happen yeah the secret I mean another
secret is Indy bio is really a design
program for biology and for biologists
it's productizing biology to solve
massive problems and that's that's all
we do and so if you look at a lot of the
things that we a lot of the tools we use
for mentoring and a lot of the sort of
vices we give and all that there's
really de based in design and so you
know from talking to people and going
out and talking to customers and getting
sales you know traction is everything
sit we have a saying sale solves
everything yeah and so sales solves
everything because you understand your
customer and you know what they want and
until you have a sale you can't say that
and if you're a therapeutics a company
well now you know how do you design a
preclinical trial how do you design the
preclinical studies such that you're in
vivo makes sense or you're in vitro make
sense relative to what you're trying to
accomplish either for an IND package for
the FDA or for a farm partnership and
what are the endpoints needed so all of
those things can be designed
then with the same amount of money you
could design an experiment that's
elegant that proves to skeptics you know
that your target is valid or not or you
could design something that doesn't
prove to skeptics even with the same
results so in the experimental design
becomes really critical finding product
market fit becomes really critical
designing a deal becomes really critical
you know really design perfuses through
all aspects of what we do and like how
you also said that it's either it has to
impact a billion people or what was the
other one
billion dollars billion dollar market
size yeah again Oh thinking big so at
that point I mean what we're the latest
of thinking for indie bio is as we've
started to really collect this knowledge
and see what is working for scale is now
starting to really think about
businesses as owning entire value chess
stacks so don't be a a component in
someone else's product but be the
end-to-end product completely yeah and I
think that's becoming more and more what
we're starting to help entrepreneurs
understand is sure you could make this
compat someone else adds to their
product and then sells to the customer
or if your thing is so much better or so
it helps that end product so much better
learn the other stuff that that custom
that that that you're that you're
selling to is doing and just own the
customer yourself and that's a that's
the next big leap for many of these
scientists as they become entrepreneurs
right the first step is oh man I can
productize this thing that I've been
working on on the bench right that's
already a meant massive mentally the
second mental leap is I can now take
this thing that's productized and now
own an entire value chain to disrupt an
industry that's a very very big next
step and
and I see there's you know there are
some that don't make the switch from
scientist entrepreneur and then there's
some that don't make the switch from
entrepreneur to massive scale launch
broom yeah so there's actually a
differentiation between two and so we're
now starting to see okay we have real
tools around helping people make the
first one yes yeah that's the first one
first yeah so you know it's an even
let's get to the second one and what
tools can you help them understand and
get used to applying to their lives to
get to that more massive scale okay give
us a a really like civilization driven
civilization design driven visual of
this so we have the agriculture systems
are just kind of I mean just blamele
crappy in many ways like the slaughter
evolved animals across the world but
there's also you know amazing things
like the fact that we learned how to
plant food next to our owns and harvest
it so fast and then and feed lots of
people but in there are certain aspects
to the way that we do this process of
feeding people that is just that's
horrible there are certain aspects to
the way that we provide that we provide
health care it's more like sick care we
just wait for people to have disease
before we actually do anything about it
which is horrible so horrible way to
look at things how can we tweak the
human body along the way to to keep it
healthy so that it doesn't even get sick
in the first place so so all these
different ways that you're leveraging
biotechnology give us this like vision
in the agriculture space and how your
companies are really at the forefront of
the vision and same thing in the
healthcare mmm-hmm so yeah I think
really you know you've said it a couple
times preventing disease in the first
place is the most important thing so we
start thinking about food and nutrition
right which is related to the
agriculture side that's a I think that's
one of the most misunderstood or poorly
understood areas
we have which is remarkable because it's
the thing we do three times a day yeah
minimum right we eat and yet is a carbo
good thing or a bad thing is protein
good or bad yeah we're in what
proportions how do we know all the
studies have been done have been so
tainted by different interests that it's
hard to believe or hard to know what it
is that's that's helping us or hurting
us and so we're actually looking now for
really great nutrition companies people
we see that as another trillion-dollar
problem is food as medicine I think is
critically important thinking of
thinking of health as a holistic point
of view our mind the food we eat the how
we live how we work all of that comes
together and we're at the intersect you
know we're thinking about how do you do
things at the intersection one of the
things that's gonna change you know
civil is that you so talk about
designing civilization and I do I have
said this before think we're headed
towards something I call homo Concilio
homo Concilio be justice
so Concilio is just the Latin for
designed mm-hm so we will be able to
design ourselves our offspring and of
course it's going to be a lot of ethical
questions but the technology to do so
already exists the technology to do so
safely and repeatedly will exist very
shortly and the rest is a question of
genomics and understanding fina genotype
to phenotype now phenotype is generally
based on networks of genes working
together so it's not going to be as much
as changes one gene and then you change
your you know eye color or the shape of
your nose or whatever it's gonna be
multiple genes it's good multiple
multiple genes all working together an
extremely complicated way with you know
and the regulatory molecules involved
and so it's not a simple problem but you
is in it is a solvable problem it is
more engineering than it is fundamental
science at this point and then ethics as
well engineering ethics separating
ethics out just to see you know what's
possible versus what should be done yeah
but you know so the the the factors that
lead to what we call intelligence right
you know the ability to guess well the
factors that lead to you know the
ability to communicate well all of these
things will understand the is it'll be
it's like a graphic equalizer right some
some networks genetic networks are more
important than others and then we'll
find key pathways within those networks
that are targets and they might be
genetic targets they might be regulatory
targets but they'll be it'll be possible
to attenuate them and these are these
are now targets for the design of human
behavior or humanity and I think we're
crossing over into that already a little
bit right I have to go there for two
kids two girls and we did genetic
screening right and of course for myself
for my wife and god forbid if we had you
know the childhood Down syndrome or
something like that you do it early
enough to have the ability to terminate
the pregnancy right and that's a
widespread thing so already we're making
decisions based on genetic screening and
granite is for good reason
now the ethical area becomes well what
makes you what was the real decision
right oh there's a heart defect okay
that's a good it's a really good reason
to augment that genome right fix that
heart defect yeah what about making the
heart 20% stronger I don't know I think
that becomes a really interesting
question well you know what if you're a
nation state that says you know what our
competitive advantage in the next three
generations is going to be to be able to
be stronger faster
smarter than any other nation on the
planet and you Institute that it's a
crazy these are the questions this
technology raises no one has the answer
for this you're coming up with the big
can of worms that we talked about on the
show a lot how do we work across the
world together as all these different
technologies are not proliferating with
AI robotics biotech genetic engineering
even what's coming up with space and
blockchain and all these different
technologies how do we ensure that
across all of the different borders when
you look at the Earth from the moon no
borders that's right just seven and a
half billion people but when you zoom in
on a satellite view of the US and Mexico
you see that border and you see there's
two different the socioeconomic status
is completely in there right there next
to each other so well how do you think
that we're gonna end up collaborating on
this together across the world
you know that's a good question I don't
know the answer to that right now I mean
honestly I I think the I think
collaboration was the key
I like that you use that word and I
think having a very strong ethical line
is gonna be incredibly important you
know if this is type of technology are
only available for pay let's say for the
one percent and the one percents now
giving a genetic advantage to their
children well that gap it becomes
insurmountable within generations and so
in the very long run we need to mitigate
that and move all of humanity forward so
that that line that you see from space
as you as you put it disappears because
I think the the power of biology is
something that allows us to think about
living in a world of surplus
you know and that's something we you
know we talk about Greta Mars cuz it's
not gonna you know be around anymore
it's not true necessarily like I think
we can we can have earth be Oh a place
of surplus with double the population as
long as we understand efficiencies and
how we use it and you know just like
with global warming it'll take all
nations working together to adopt codes
to not pollute and emit carbon and add
to co2 we're gonna have to do the same
thing with genetics we're gonna have to
do the same thing with the power of AI
and I mean when you think about AI
controlled weaponry that's like a truly
horrifying thought I mean and so we have
to agree to not do these things it seems
that there's a base level of agreeing to
do things like eradicating suffering
that that seems to be this bare basic
level of agreement that the child is
going to suffer in some way genetically
and we have the ability to fix it we
should democratize that to the point
where it's as cheap potentially even
free funded by the collective as
possible so that way yeah I agree and
now you're getting to the other part of
civilization design which i think is
really important and not talked about
enough which is the cost of health care
which is crazy so you know we there's a
great article that was put out recently
I can't remember who they said you know
what is the business model of curing
disease sustainable right if you're in
the business of curing disease and your
businesses sell these little pills right
and you give one pill to someone and
they never need that pill again look how
much you're gonna charge for that pill
right and so you're in this conundrum I
think that's a that's a real thing to
think about and especially if we're
talking about capitalism yeah as a
predominant economic structure or to
that that it hangs everything together
and profit driving being the driver well
then that that is a big question around
health care
it should be democratized it should be
available to everyone but then how do
you fund the research and the average of
600 million dollars was required to
create one cancer therapy yeah that's
the average it takes to make a drug so
all of that needs to be recouped
otherwise why bother you know going into
that business and so I think it's an
open question is is it a state-funded
thing do these things move out of the
capitalist I mean I'm a venture
capitalist right like literally in the
title of my job and so you know but at
the same time my fund biotech because I
think these problems are really
important and it's you have a
philosophical and ethical grounding and
what you're doing that's what's missing
I think in a lot of the conversations
around funding things thank you yeah
yeah I just think that's our like it
yeah yeah let's see okay let's see now
[Laughter]
all right let's do some pot let's do
some power rounds through this through
this ending what are your thoughts about
regulation because a lot of people say
that regulations really important so
that way we don't have all of the the
harmful effects of not having any
regulation that would be bad but also
regulation can stifle innovation where
do you think that harmony exists
regulatory for therapeutics and for
medical devices let's go there but then
all almost everything really yeah well
for a human health care I think is
critically important the drive for
profit will put more lives at risk if
there wasn't a regulatory body to stop
it so I'm a VC that embraces a
regulatory I think now the question is
how do you make regulatory as efficient
as possible so that we're not discarding
great drugs potential therapeutics and
we're actually in
embracing innovation and giving you a
true test of how it works or not and not
over inflating cost right so there's an
optimization game that needs to happen
but I think regulatory is is importantly
you know in regulation in general in
tech is it has been around commerce to
protect commerce right so if you look at
taxicab medallions as the most recent
like the uber versus the world sort of
thing right taxis had medallions and
that was a way of protecting the
business and creating a price floor well
we all know in economics but that's not
true competition and through competition
the customer always wins and so uber was
able to break that and literally the
customers won and ubers has become the
most valuable private company in the
world in doing so so regulatory is is
different in different places I think
when regulation is protecting Commerce I
think it should be broken
I you know bike protected parties I
think regulatory that is protecting
human health and consumer interests I
think it's important to keep so there is
a balance I'm you know I'm not as
libertarian as others in that all
government is bad I think your
regulation is provides a helpful
framework especially in a capitalist
society where profit is the motivator
correct and then so then what about the
follow-up to that being that where where
do you where do you find yourself fun
where do you find the optimal optimal
place to be for for teaching children
into the world the concept of wanting to
make great impact in value and I'll make
enough money to sustain that research
and development but then also have a
social cause or some some sort of aspect
to your philosophy that has to do with
the wanting to take capital and D
materialize yourself away from diamonds
and all that crap and move more towards
how do I help the person that I'm
walking by across the street that
doesn't have a home or that doesn't have
the mental state to to get themselves up
on their feet
how do we make the transition from
diamonds to homeless people it's a good
question because there's some what is
something I think about every day with
my two little girls there are three and
one and I'm always thinking to myself
how do I raise the very best people
possible you know it's a I take that
more importantly than any drug than my
job you know that is the most important
thing in my life and so you know I think
I would like number one my wife and I
live by this rule we try to create more
than we consume so always creating
something right like whether that's
artwork or whether that's design work or
whether that's you know we want to be
creating weather you know and and not
consuming this question that whether
that's a television or Facebook or you
know Instagram you know like those are
that's a that's a tug of war and your
time is gonna go in one bucket or the
other so you want to try to put it in
the create bucket I love that and so the
other side is now when you're in the
Creed bucket what do you want to create
and so you could be inspired now by the
problems around you right by the
homeless plight that you might see
that's one of the reasons we put it on
Jesse Street right there's a lot of
mentally ill people that are becoming
drug addicts and there there's a
methadone clinic above us and it's a
stark reminder every single day that
there's a lot of you know you hear you
it's easy to think about the Silicon
Valley as this bubble of technology and
money it's hard to think of Silicon
Valley as that technology that bubble
when you go to Indy bio Jessie Street
thank you and it's a daily reminder of
what we have to do and so that's you
know you can see it as unpleasant or you
can see as inspiration yeah I'm trying
to teach my girls to see the world's
problems as inspiration versus something
that should be brushed under the rug yep
we need more parents like for thinking
that way okay how about we ask you what
do you think is the most beautiful thing
in the world besides my wife and my two
girls I think that's really it I mean
those are the two you know the three
most beautiful things in my life but you
know I think the other you know if I
take it outside of that I'll say it's
watching someone take their life's work
and turn it into something that creates
human value yeah that transformation is
something I've seen over and over again
now and it never stops striking me as so
impactful I mean it's like you know to
me it's a yeah that's a pretty
remarkable moment it's like wow they
wouldn't be doing this this company
wouldn't exist if they didn't have that
space at ndio to try and learn and fail
and get up and then do it again and then
all of a sudden their life's work is
being used to change someone else's life
as opposed to be a paper that is sitting
online somewhere that has three hits and
two people you know and maybe one of
those people skimmed it you know it's
like and that is a remarkable thing and
that's that's something that's really
beautiful me well I watch that over and
over again and we love idea figuring out
how to get children to find that similar
kind of inspiration of bringing value to
the world their work bringing value to
the world and we'll try and figure out
how exactly to do that with the children
that we're raising do you think we're
alone in the cosmos mathematically no i
would i would definitely say we're not
alone now what is the other life form
looks like who who knows I mean there's
a there's you know different evolution
different environmental conditions will
give rise to different evolutionary
traits you know on a sulfuric world we
might be light you know you look at our
hydrothermal vents you know you have
life in the darkness
you know eating sulfur as an energy
source so and if that kept going you
know keeps going who what would that
evolve into that it's a good question um
one I I worry that the distances are too
large you know for us to ever find out
but I don't think we're alone I do you
think we're in a computer simulation no
I I mean I I understand again the
mathematical argument for it but I'll
take des cartes
approach and say it doesn't matter you
know you know I I may be fooled but if I
have these senses and I can think for
myself and therefore I am me and I can
be that if I'm a simulation you know it
doesn't really matter would you say is
the deepest emotion you've ever felt mmm
I mean love that's an easy one I think
that's the you know love is something
that's strongest a love and hope let me
let me buttress that I think when I
didn't have love I had hope and then
that hope got replaced by love it you
know so those are the two things here we
go we're gonna end it with so many of
our pieces into the biotech equation now
and we're gonna have so it's being
accelerated at crazy rates we're
absolutely grateful to have people like
you working on this Thank You Harvin
thank you so much thank you so much to
the shows yeah real pleasure great
questions was it a good time yeah I did
I did thank you so we'll see you soon
yeah we'll see you guys soon thanks for
tuning in indie bio Co we'll put the
link in the bio do check them out who do
apply as applications closing for the
next cohort yes in a couple weeks I it's
on the the deadlines like right up there
cool so the couple weeks left until
their application deadline closes do
check them out
give them some support as well on their
mission watch it watch their content
they have so many of these portfolio
companies we have a couple almost like a
dozen interviews of the portfolio
companies as well so go look at those
and share them share this share what
they're doing with other people around
you think about what life could be like
if agriculture was more sustainable if
health care was more sustainable so join
us in this biotech revolution lightness
on the biotech Renaissance
it's a Renaissance it's a biotech
Renaissance exactly and we are we're
coming at you hot
give us a subscribe give us a like give
us a comment below let us know your
thoughts
join us on patreon so we can make this
process sustainable we'd greatly
appreciate that support thank you Ron
Vargas are producing partner and we will
see you guys soon
[Music]
you
[Music]